من بيروت سمعنا الخبير والعسكري
والاستراتيجي العميد الغاز حنا صيد الياس
كيف تقرا
تطورات الساعات الاخيره لسيما خط سير
وتحرك وامكانيه تحرك قوات فاجنر حتى
اللحظه
حسن الغريب هو هشاشه الامن في الداخل
الروسي يعني عندما نتحدث عن 25 الف مقاتل
لفاجنر حتى ولو كانوا من النخب حتى ولو
كانوا ذوي الخبره المتقدمه وقاتلوا في
بخموت او في غيرها الدخول الى روستوف دون
مقاومه
حتى بانضمام البعض اليهم الوصول الى مركز
قياده القوات الجنوبيه الروسيه او القطاع
الجنوبي بالاضافه الى قياده العمليات
في اوكرانيا وبالتالي الاستمرار باتجاه
برونيتش وهذا امر غريب عجيب يعني كيف يمكن
ان تدخل الى مدينه مساحتها ما تقارب 400
كيلو متر مربعه فيها مليون نسمه فيها
قيادات عسكريه مهمه هي
محور او مركز ثقل اللوجستيه تحدثت حسن
حضرتك عن الام فور هناك الذي ياتي من
رستوف باتجاه ماريوبول والى خرسون وهذا
امر مهم جدا ايضا هي محور كيف يمكن الوصول
اليها نتحدث عن موازين القوى تقريبا 378
طوافه
للجيش الروسي ما يقارب الالف ومئه طائره
نفاسه اغلبها من الجيل الرابع انه الا
يكفي ان تصعد طائره وتضرب
التمرد بعد ان وصف قانونيا في الكرملين
على انه تمرد يعني اليوم اما هناك تقاطع
من الداخل
وكلما سار بالدرب ينضم اليه المزيد من
العسكر او ان هناك فعلا هشاشه في الداخل
الروسي يعني فلنتامل ان هناك دوله وليس
منظمه بسيطه تدخل الى روسيا وتصل الى
منطقه
فيروناج 500 كلم عن رستوف يعني هذا امر
غريب عجيب ولكن هذا الامر سيؤثر كثيرا
كثيرا كثيرا على منظومه الامن الروسي في
الداخل على صوره القوه التي اعطاها الرئيس
بوتين وعلى العمليات في داخل اوكرانيا
يعني
ضيفنا من موسكو
مترافيوفيتش قبل قليل كان لافت حديث خصوصا
في نقطه معينه عندما اسرنا هذه الاشكاليه
عندما قال انه لربما طبعا يضعه في اطار
الاحتمال ولكن من له اسس انه اذا ما اعطي
امر باطلاق النار لربما لن ينفذ امر اطلاق
النار على وهذا الامر يعني مثير للتساؤل
كيف يمكن ان تفسر هذه النقطه
حسن هذا الامر شهدناه في الاداء للجيش
الروسي على الساحه الاوكرانيه منذ ما بدات
الحرب بالعام 2022 22 شباط هل نستذكر فعلا
القافله التي طولها 70 او 80 كم من
الدبابات وتوقفت لايام معدوده بسبب يعني
الضرب بها من قبل بعض المقاتلين
بصواريخ مضاده للمدرعات يعني هذا امر
اعطانا
نوعيه معينه من الاداء على صعيد العسكري
اليوم ما زرعه في وقت من الاوقات في
بدايات الحرب الرئيس بوتين يحصده اليوم
لماذا لانه اليوم عندما نتحدث عن بريكوجي
نتحدث عن جيش قائم بحد ذاته والدليل على
ذلك هو ما يحدث الان 25 الف جندي في داخل
الروسي في داخل روسيا لا نعرف ماذا ماذا
يوجد في افريقيا مثلا او في سوريا فاذا
انت امام جيش قائم بحد ذاته لا وحده
للقياده يعني جيش يقاتل بالمطلق من ضمن
وزاره الدفاع ووزاره الدفاع لا تمون عليه
لا تملك القرار عليه هو يقرر ماذا يفعل هو
يهاجم ماذا يفعل حتى حاليا يهدد موسكو
العاصمه يعني اليوم عندما تتحدث عن موسكو
بال 1812 حسن
احتلها نابليون وصل اليها الى حد ما
المغول في عده عده مرات حتى بولندا
احتلتها وهذا هاجس في العقل الروسي
العاصمه العاصمه ثم العاصمه اليوم نتحدث
عن الف كيلو متر من روستوف الى موسكو وانه
ولا احد يقف ونضع الشاحنات وامكانيه تفجير
الجسور هذا امر هذا الامر يعني
انت عسكري سابق
وعميد وخبير عسكري ايضا ما رايك بالقول
انه ليست هناك احتياطات في موسكو وليست
هناك ليس هناك عديد يكفي
لحمايه موسكو ووقف تقدم
قوات
حسن دائما في العمليات العسكريه يخطط عاده
للسيناريو السيء ويامل المخطط ان ياتي
السيناريو الممتاز في بدايات الحرب عندما
خطط الرئيس بوتين خطط للسيناريو الممتاز
دون الاخذ بعين الاعتبار ماذا سيحصل
وعندما حصل غير المنتظر بدا بالاستدعاء ل
300 الف من الجنود هرب ما يقارب المليون
شخص واكثر الى البلدان المجاوره وبالتالي
اصبح عبء على الرئيس بوتين اذا اراد ان
يطوع في الداخل ولكن هذا الامر يدل ان ليس
هناك من احتياط ولكن هذا الامر قد ياخذنا
الى امر مهم ممكن حسن ممكن اعلان حاله
الطوارئ تغيير اسم العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه وبالتالي اعلان الحرب وتحويل
الاقتصاد والصناعات الروسيه الى صناعات
حربيه او اقتصاد حربي وهذا الامر قد يغير
كل المعادله فهل ممكن الرئيس بوتين ان
يقدم على هذه الخطوه هذا امر يعني
بان لناظره قريب
هل لديك اي تساؤل او علامات استفهام مثلا
حول
حول القيادات العسكريه وموقفها مما يجري
حسنا عندما عندما بدات الحرب من خطط لها
هو الرئيس بوتين جرسيف رئيس الاركان
وبغياب الاستخبارات وهذا امر فريد من نوعه
تاريخيا ايام الاتحاد السوفيتي كان يخطط
بين الرئيس الزعيم السوفيتي الاستخبارات
والجيش كان ينفذ هذه المره في الدومباس
وحتى في القرم حصل العكس يعني شوربه هو
المسؤول هو المسؤول وبالتالي حتى الوزير
لبروف تفاجات في هذا الامر اليوم يجب ان
نعرف ما هي موقف
الاستخبارات الروسيه الداخليه الخارجيه
وحتى العسكريه ما هو موقف القيادات
العسكريه من مستوى سيروفيكين وما غيره او
القياسيه فهل الكل ينتظر لمعرفه من هو
الرابح بالاضافه الى هذا الامر عندما ركبت
تنظيم الرئيس بوتين ركبها بطريقه ان هو
فعلا المسيطر على كل هذه التداعيات وعلى
كل هذه الفروقات من ضمن مبدا فرق تسود
اليوم يدفع الثمن مع بريجوجين فاذا اليوم
لا امكانيه
ان يطيح بالنظام بروسيه الا اذا كان هناك
تعاون من جهتين اساسيتين جهه وزاره الدفاع
وهذا الامر غير ممكن من الاركان وهذا
الامر غير ممكن ومن الاستخبارات هنا تبدا
علامه الاستفهام هنا تبدا علامه الاستفهام
وهنا يطرح السؤال هل يمكن لبريجوجين ان
يدخل في مغامره غير محسوبه ومن دون ان
يكون لديه اي دعم داخلي
ولو من اي جهه نافذه
ممكن ممكن حسن ولكن بخمسه وعشرين الف جندي
ان تحتل تذهب الى موسكو وهذا امر غير
معروف اللهم الا اذا كان كلما احتل منطقه
ينضم اليها العسكر وبالتالي ينضم وياخذ من
القواعد العسكريه الاسلحه والعتاد وما
شابه وهذا امر ليس بالامر السهل ان ينضم
فريق جديد اليك كي تقاتل لانه من يقاتل مع
فاجنير هو من يقبض المال يعني هو لقاء
المال يقاتل فاذا هناك هدف غير الهدف
الوطني والقومي وما شابه فهل يستطيع ان
يضم او يجمع حوله تلك القيادات الاساسيه
حتى الان لا اعتقد انه قادر حتى بامكان
بامكانياته العسكريه هو ليس قادرا يبقى
كيف سيكون رئيس بوتين يعني تردد الرئيس
بوتين باعطاء الامر عسكريا بضرب بريكوجين
هذا امر غريب خاصه انه الرئيس بوتين حرك
كل القواعد القانونيه يعني موضوع الارهاب
موضوع
التمرد وما شابه وبالتالي يبقى الامر
بالقضاء العسكري من سيطلق النار على
بريكوجين او على القوات
هذا امر يعني فعلا لا اعرف من من هو قادر
هذه الصوره طبعا
توحينا من جديد الى الميدان
الان القوات الاوكرانيه تتحدث عن تقدم في
اماكن كانت اساسا مسيطر عليها من قبل
القوات الروسيه في عام 2014 كما تشير الى
تقدم في مناطق زابولوجيا
وباخ مود
هل يمكن فعلا
للجبهه ان
تتراخى بهذا الشكل بما يسمح للقوات
الاوكرانيه بان تتقدم بهذه السرعه
ايضا حسن اليوم اصبحت الجبهه الاوكرانيه
900 كم مرتبطه بالواقع الداخلي الروسي
يعني انتقلت الديناميكيه والفوضى من
الجبهه 900 كيلومتر الى الداخل واصبح
الروسي يقاتل الروسي وهذا امر خطير جدا
واذا تحدثنا عن هذا التقدم لقوات فاجنر في
هذه المسافه لهذه المسافه وبهذه السرعه
فهذا امر يعني ان هناك هشاشه في الداخل
وليس هناك من قوات اساسيه واذا لم يكن
هناك مقوات اساسيه ويريد الرئيس بوتين ان
يضرب فاغنير عليه ان يستدعي بعض القوات من
اين هل هي من الشرق هل هي من القوات
الخاصه حول
روموسكو هذا الامر يدلنا ان هناك نقص كيف
تدير اليوم عمليتين عسكريتين واحده في
الداخل تصبح حيويه حياه او موت للرئيس
بوتين ولروسيه ولنظام لان هذه العمليه اذا
نجحت مع بريكوزين قد تؤدي الى تفتيت
الروسيه باقلياتها وما شابه وحركات
استقلال وهذا امر شهدناه عند سقوط الاتحاد
السوفياتي فاذا من اين سياتي بهذه القوات
بالاضافه حسن الى المعنويات للعسكر يعني
من اين تاتي يعني منظومه العمل اللوجستيه
والعسكريه والقياده وما شابه تعطلت اليوم
فاذا اليوم هذه فرصه اساسيه مهمه جدا
ونافزه مهمه جدا للقوات الاوكرانيه ان
تبدا بمكان ما ولكن يبقى الامر المهم جدا
حتى الان قد يصاعد الرئيس بوتين على
الساحه الاوكرانيه ليقول ان الداخل الروسي
شيء بسيط وهو داخلي او في حال خرق الجيش
الاوكراني وذهبنا الى ما يسمى بالدينامو
المتساقط قد يذهب الى ما ليس بالحسبان
استعمال سلعه غير تقليدي حسن شكرا لك
العميد الياس حنان الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي كنت معنا من بيروت